جهود كبيره كل الامكانيات الان فتحت امام
فرق الانقاذ وزاره الدفاع التركيه اعلنت
عن ان طائراتها جاهزه بالكامل الطائرات
العسكريه لنقل فرق الانقاذ الى المناطق
المتضرره ايضا هيئه او رئاسه الشؤون
الدينيه قالت ان المواطنين الذين يبيتون
الان في العراق بامكانهم القدوم الى
المساجد غير المتضرره بعد التاكد من
سلامتها طبعا من قبل السلطات المختصه
نتحدث ايضا اعيد التفكير بان السلطات
تركيا اطلقت حاله الانذار من المستوى
الرابع وبالتالي الحاجه او اعلان الحاجه
او قبول مساعدات دوليه هذا ينبع بشكل او
باخر محمد على ان حجم الدمار كبير وانا
الزلزال كبير وانا اثار الزلزال الماديه
والبشريه ربما ستكون كبيره هذا الزلزال
وفق كل المعطيات الحاليه التي بين ايدينا
الان هو الاكبر منذ اسط الذي وقع في عام
1999 وراح ضحيته حوالي 17
وربما استجابه لما يحدث الان في تركيا وفي
سوريا
بتقييم حاجات المناطق المنقوبه بالزلزال
في تركيا وسوريا نتحدث هنا عن تركيا وعن
سوريا تركيا ربما
دفاع المدني وسلطات المختصه هناك لديها
الامكانيات اللازمه لانقاذ